hello there welcome to
what was that it was you don't like my
hello there
no just just the listener all these bits
before like picking up a phone and
pretending you were talking to someone
then all of a sudden you got serious
here's the problem here's the and i'm
explaining this because we're using this
open but
i i don't you think we should gourley
this is a yes i do okay so basically
they need to know we were screwing
around acting like fools and then
matt said okay let's get going and i
suddenly switched from i have an
old-timey phone on my desk and i was
pretending i was doing some stupid bit
as i do and then it was time to start
our supposedly comedic podcast but you
said let's get going so i put the phone
down took one second and just went hello
there and you guys
start laughing and
because
and you're right it's so stupid i'm not
you know i'm not this respected figure
that needs to say and now the news
uh you know of course uh still
you know it's it's it's absurd
why did i go from doing stupid bits with
you this happened before with you guys
that weren't being recorded yeah just
being dumb and sona saying i'm stupid
and me saying yeah well idiot called and
it says it's you whatever whatever dumb
stuff we're doing tonight hit me with
whatever you had rolled up through the
computer yeah you're doing something
weird we're on zoom and i have a glasses
case and i was trying to jab you with it
through zoom so all of this
uh absolutely uh inane foolishness and
then gourley says not it's time to start
the eye operation on the patient which
then it would make sense to like okay
guys settle down right girly what you're
saying is it's time to stop this
foolishness to begin
the foolishness the actual [ __ ] dick
around begins yes yeah stop this
[ __ ] dick around and then i'm gonna
pull this lever and so you i said okay
and then suddenly just ch when did you
this tone of hello there like well who's
that guy you become the full cronkite
let's try again we'll keep all this
stuff but just be yourself ready three
two one well sona's bad
what what
what i'm sorry i thought you wanted me
to be myself no why you admit you're
kind of
that wasn't creative at all that was so
bad oh wait you don't think it's
creative so you you think i was just
saying the truth no i respect i respect
your slams when they have some
creativity behind it when you're just
like sona's bad here's why picasso was
great oh come on he was an incredible
draftsman an incredible uh great man
yeah but also no i didn't say that able
to uh
realistic he could he was he was great
at depicting he could depict anything he
could draw the human hand beautifully
which is uh
very difficult to do he had studied
anatomy he knew what to do but then he
blew it up by going to the simple shapes
simple shapes and that's what i just did
i've had my sophisticated sona slams but
like picasso
it's now like 1917 and i'm deciding i
gotta blow it up and do something
that'll blow everyone's mind and my new
riff is sona's bad
oh that's let's hear another one of
these blown up sona slams
that's my that's my cubism oh my god
sona's unprofessional there
you are stupid no i don't like this
cubism because it's true it's not even
like it's like funny because it's
like yeah i am unprofessional
date some more facts let's uh
no no i uh no i just is my cubist period
and you guys say this is no good just
saying sona's bad
but when they do put and i believe this
is artwork what we're doing
when this is put when yes 100 years from
now when people want to buy
the digital snippet of me saying sona's
bad it's going to be at christy's
auction house it's going to be
framed somehow don't ask me how and it's
going to be worth 35 million dollars
which will be about 350 dollars
i know that was such an austin powers
moment where dr evil is like and the
ransom is ten thousand dollars
[Laughter]
dr evil what oh
it's not 1968 anymore